Where are you from
and what are you currently studying?
I'm Jake. Um,
my background from Seychelles
and I'm studying
a Bachelor of biodiversity and conservation.
Why did you choose to study that degree?
I just wanted to do something that would help
the environment and somehow wouldn't get bored of.
What kind of job opportunities
await for you when you're finished?
You can work in ecological consultant.
You work in a government,
um, run in sort of,
I guess, environments, a law.
It's really the first degree.
What is a job market like?
Will there be a lot of
jobs waiting for you when you finish?
Yeah, they will be.
Um, especially in the government.
There's a lot of governmental jobs,
um, also private sector jobs.
So what advice would you give someone
who is wanting to go into the program that you're in?
If you're passionate about the environment,
if you like animals,
you like nature,
it's not boring
and you would enjoy it if you like the environment.